now when it comes to space and time i've
heard you describe it as a data
compression tool for us conscious agents
why do we need as conscious agents data
compression why is there a limit to how
much we can process
well that's going to be a very
interesting
thing for this deeper theory to to try
to explain
why is there this limit it
it may be that all conscious systems are
necessarily finite
and that's one theory that i'm playing
with that the
the realm of conscious agents may be
such that
there is no bound to the complexity that
a conscious agent can have
but it's but it's always finite so it's
as big as you wish
but but always finite and in which case
um no matter how complex you are
compared to all the possible complexity
your measure zero your probability is
zero right you have
so so in that sense
if but but there may be a really really
deep
point of view in which consciousness
may be taking these
dividing itself into sort of
subconsciousnesses which are sort of
different perspectives
that are looking at the whole and these
different perspectives would necessarily
then have limited information about the
whole
they'll only be able to see through an
interface but necessarily
right this is it's sort of the kind of
thing like
right in the twitter verse
i can it's a there's tens of millions of
users
billions of tweets i could talk with one
or two twitter users
extensively and follow all of their
tweets maybe
if i really into it maybe a hundred of
them
and follow all their tweets but there's
10 million
or more twitter users so i there's no
way
there's absolutely no way so if i want
to
get a feel for what's happening in
general
in the twitterverse i'm going to need to
have some kind of data compression tool
some visualization tool
right we see this all the time whenever
whenever there's big
social media data we use visualization
tools to see what's going on
and that's what i think space time is
space time
is our headset we've mistaken the
headset for reality
we've assumed that space and time are
fundamental or
space time is fundamental we've assumed
that that's subjective reality
and it's just a rookie mistake it's our
headset it's our visualization tool
and what we're what's behind it is this
vast network of other conscious agents
now it's one thing for me to say this it
sounds you know
interesting but where's the beef and
where the beef is going to have to come
from
is a precise mathematical description of
the dynamics of conscious agents
so it's for those interested in the math
it's
dynamics on networks so it's network
theory
so the kind of stuff that you use when
you're studying like the internet
and um um the dynamics of information
flow on the internet and so forth it's
that kind of mathematics
so it's it's it's proposing a specific
mathematical dynamics on a network of
conscious agents
then the way i think it'll go is that
the asymptotic behavior
of that dynamics which is that
that just means you can't see every
single tweet
you can't interact with every single
user but you can see the long term
trends
what are the things that are trending
long term what are the big
picture kinds of that's what i mean by
the asymptotics what what happens
if you look at it over a long period of
time what are the like the patterns over
a long period of time
and i think that that is
what is behind space time and and
modern physics what they're seeing what
with the physicists right now when they
try to get structures beyond space-time
you know they're trying to take the next
step beyond space-time
they they are seeing some interesting
structures called positive geometries
amplitude sociohedra and so forth these
positive geometries
i want the direction i'm going is to
show that those positive geometry
structures that they're coming up with
are representations of the asymptotic
behavior
of this dynamics of conscious agents and
if i can do that
then i will be able to use their work
and pull the threat all the way from a
theory of conscious agents and their
dynamics through
the asymptotics of that into these
positive geometries that they found
and then they tell you how to go from
that to the actual
prediction of scattering events like at
the large hadron collider
so that's my goal the beef will be if i
can start with a theory of consciousness
look at it at its asymptotics and show
that the asymptotics of that theory
consciousness
through this route that the physicists
have found already leads to the
scattering amplitudes
that we can then test at the at the
large hadron collider
that's where we have the beef